you are someone who has spent the last
20 years focusing on training especially
for hypertrophy you are someone that has
won pretty much every single title on
the planet
you have 10 exercises that you can do
for the rest of your life in order to
maintain as good of a physique as you
can
what are they and why
ten that's very specific ten I just
figured I just figured that would be
enough for you to get each different
muscle group right okay so what are the
what are the longest levers that you can
pull when it comes to maintaining size
or increasing size for a lot of
obviously compound lists so you're
looking at your deadlifts uh your bench
press
um and your squats they're always good
again these are things that I have had
to adapt over the years because of um
injuries and things training silly when
I was younger okay there's three there's
three there
um hanging leg raise for core it's one
of the hardest mid-sections if you do it
properly I think it's one of the hardest
uh mid-section exercises but it's
phenomenal for your transverse abdomenes
your upper and lower abdominals
everything just it's a great
I feel like that was something that
helped me build my my midsection you've
got one of the like acclaimed best mid
sections in all of Fitness what are the
cues that people get wrong when they're
doing hanging leg roses so the create
momentum this swing which um
I think that has a bit to do CrossFit
with this Kipping Malarkey and momentum
stuff that that came into play a fair
few years ago but
um yeah I think swinging um I think
using the hip flexors instead of the the
midsection how do you know if you're
doing that you'll feel it you'll feel it
down your quads
um what's the cue someone's doing a
someone's listening to this hanging from
a bar right now what is the cue for them
to go from I'm hanging straight to I'm
doing a leg raise
that makes it work appropriately so he's
talking the hips in and making sure
you're Contracting you're up and lower
abdominals before anything else so it's
always keeping them fully contracted
Minds multiple connection is is a huge
thing I believe in that so much yeah
Mike Thurston does the same yeah and the
thing is the last few years I've done
that so much more now as I've got older
and more mature I'm not just trying to
lift heavy weight and trying to Ego lift
and since I've done that the muscle
maturity and how my body's developed
it's just exponential I just wish I'd
done it five six years ago
um so yeah so I think that's very
important my into muscle connection with
hanging leg razors you're going to an L
are you going up to touch the bar so
either so I used to do all the way to
the top
um but I alternate now so I'll just do a
bit of both
um I think there's there's a place for
both of them but I think that when you
go past a certain point you are
recruiting all the muscle groups and so
if you want to just isolate your
midsection just go to 90 degrees how do
you do Progressive overload on that or
do you
you or you could add weights to you I
don't personally no because I was
obsessed with my midsection growing up
as you say Rob Richards was the guy who
got me obsessed with it so I wanted to
be on the front covers like Rob was I
you see all the magazines and I
tried to treat my midsection like any
other muscle but some a lot of people
think with the midsection you should um
train 30 minutes after every session or
why every other muscle part we train we
train to break the muscle fibers down
heavy a lot of load we break the muscle
fire that we let them recover two three
four days before we hit him again and
that's how I
looked and viewed my midsection so I'd
give them two full hour sessions with a
three to four day rest between and add
the six to eight rep range really heavy
the thing with that I start to develop
really chunky ABS blocky ABS but in the
end it started to look a bit distended
because I'd gone too far with it and I
was causing so many back problems had
slipped discs from it and basically it's
because I was too front heavy too front
strong so it took a lot of years to
start having to uh hyper extend for
every
crunch I did they said I had to do two
hyper extensions wow so yeah it was you
needed to compensate for all of that
anterior strength that you developed and
so now I don't tend to go too heavy and
we do a lot of own body weight stuff
okay cool so you've got four you've got
squat bench deadlift yeah okay hanging
leg raises six more slots to keep your
body
uh so so I'll go with uh some isolation
work so we'll we'll probably go with
like an incline dumbbell chest just
because
um you can do very a lot of different
variations on that but I think it's
great for development
um
shoulders aren't getting much work at
the moment
all right shoulder press we'll go with a
dumbbell shoulder press because it's
great for isolation unilateral
um and that's quite important
um obviously
so we need to do some hamstring work so
we would do
I would
I would say stiff like deadlift but now
we I think if we're going to try and
create some growth I think we're gonna
go for like a lion hamstring curl heavy
you prefer a lying to a seated
I do yes
um yeah I do but I don't know if that's
down to the fact I just get better
contraction off that I think it's
personal preference
um in my eyes like I've always said that
with any type of exercises if you feel
an exercise more than another stick with
it Go With It do the extra sets and Reps
on that particular exercise because
that's where you're going to get the
most out of it if you're doing an
exercise because someone else has told
you to do it and you're not getting that
my internal connection or you're not
revealing it there's no point and that's
that's what I love about bodybuilding as
well nutrition and training you adapt it
to you it's it's an individual sport you
can have people around you supporting it
but your metabolism and the way you
train the way you eat it all falls on
you so learn the body yourself and adapt
as you go okay three left what have you
got
I've lost where we are now um squat
bench deadlift hanging leg raise uh
incline chest press with dumbbells
shoulder press seated car phrase seated
calf raise oh so you want to get the
Soleus moving yeah we'll get them in
okay okay we'll cover them and then um
two left we need overhead tricep
extension rope
pivoted from the bottom of a pulley yeah
right okay yeah what are the cues that
people get wrong there because this is a
something that I absolutely love to do
but where do people go wrong quite
mechanically quite a complex movement
yeah I think you can go too heavy too
soon and start recruiting and start yeah
pulling I don't know with the shoulder I
think it's it's important to lock your
elbows in a fixed position as well as
the shoulder make sure there's no
movement there I like to elongate and
stretch it out and not a lot of people
go too far with it but I like to
overextend slightly to get a full
stretch
um and a full contraction at the top
um online
we need biceps done and then we've got
everything then what's your number one
bicep exercise
what is my number one box you know what
I'm going to say I'm going to say it um
this is a bit of an outward on this
because I've done loads of them today is
um pull-ups close grip pull-ups I know
it's a back workout but your secondary
muscle is bicep and the contraction I
get off that for my bicep every week I
hit them I always want to bring my back
up anyway so it's an excuse to just hit
the back as well but I think that's a
great
overall exercise given the fact that
you've added deadlifts in what is it
that you're finding as a physique
competitor that first off isn't
massively judged on your legs and
secondly wants a narrow torso
why would you put deadlift into that
kind of a workout so I've never believed
this with I don't know if scientifically
this is right but with deadlifting I've
never I used to deadlift every week I
don't so much now do a lot more
isolation on hyper extensions again
because I get a better contraction I do
hypers I prefer to deadlift but I do
hypers mainly but with a deadlift um
obviously recruits near off every muscle
in the in the body so it's great for for
an overall workout but
um I've lost my train of thought well
what were we saying why are you using
deadlifts given that you want to have a
small waist yeah like I say because I
train my midsection the way I do I do a
lot of ice attention in the morning and
what's that so it's basically all about
ISO holds so you breathe in fully
breathe in with you exhale every bit of
air out of the body and you crunch your
abs as hard as you can for three seconds
and then standing up standing up yeah
you can do that with any muscle parts I
it's the most monotonous thing a
bodybuilder can do but it's one of the
best things for for muscle control for
getting everything tight for condition
I challenge anybody to do this so do
we'll keep it simple three
three from the front three from the side
so you've got 300 bleaks on either side
so you've got so you inhale
hands of yet as you come down you crunch
you exhale every bit of air out you
crunch and hold it for three seconds as
hard as you can it's good to have your
top off because you need to seriously
tense do it again
and crunch try and do that 10 times and
then go to the side and then crunch down
hold and they do that 10 times and they
do that 10 times have 30 seconds rest go
again and then go again I do it five
rounds and you're literally dripping wet
through and the blood volume you get in
your midsection is insane so you can do
that with like um with your biceps or
between exercises so if you're doing um
yeah like a bicep curl you can
straighten you hold your pose a double
bicep and you hold you squeeze your
midsection you squeeze it your biceps as
hard as you can for 20 seconds say you
come out and you go straight back into
your working set it is brutal but if you
ever see on a bodybuilding stage when
when people are out there shaking
because they've got no connection
they've got no control over their bison
that's why that happens yeah yeah
there's also there's other factors what
can happen dehydrated they're tired
Etc et cetera nine times out of ten that
will be down to the fact they've not
done any ISO holes or they've not took
the time with their posing to practice
the posing
um and that's something I always pride
in myself and I remember the first few
shows I did on the Olympia stage we're
all we're all back um hitting from the
back and the guy's going like Ryan what
you know how are you holding that how
are you holding that because they're all
everyone's shaking and it's because
eight weeks out from any show 30 minutes
after my fasted cardio I'll do ISO holds
with every every pose I have to do and
every muscle group so it's it's
horrendous but these are the things that
people don't see these are like so when
you look at bodybuilding oh yeah you eat
some meals and you train uh twice a day
but it's the the little things it's the
what I've I'm I obsess over because it's
okay having a great work ethic like in
the gym or having the discipline to eat
your six meals and and not cheat
but it's also the other bits of
presentation which is so important
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
foreign